hey guys how's it going welcome to ij
likes i apologize because i usually post
this video saturday or sunday but i was
at playlist live this weekend hanging
out with you guys
maybe not all of you because i feel like
that would be physically impossible to
get all of you people into one single
room i'm still in a hotel room i'm in
miami
i think the best thing that happened
this past week was justin timberlake
released his new album
i thought it was going to be terrible
and do you know why because i absolutely
hate the song suit and tie
to my surprise the amount that i hate
that song
is the amount that i absolutely love the
rest of his album so justin the next
time you decide to release a single
please consult with me because i feel
like we can really work this out you
know you use your jay-z friend card on
not to song like suit and tie
next up my girl miley twerking in a
onesie like let's be real miley i am a
onesie queen
there's nothing that i love more than a
onesie
and i didn't even know what twerking was
i always see tyler oakley tweeting about
twerking but then i decided to dive into
the youtube searches of twerking and
i've seen some things that i will never
be able to unsee and i will not share
them with you because i do not want your
eyes to have to see the things that i
have seen
so what i have seen many many times is
this video of miley cyrus
this next video i'm not really sure how
i feel about it like i thought it was
kind of funny but then i don't really
think it's that funny so i'm kind of
somewhere in the middle justin bieber
and selena gomez we know they broke up
it's a very sad thing they're no longer
together so that's how relationships
work sometimes they don't work out no
matter how much you guys want it to you
don't get to choose people's lives david
letterman is interviewing selena gomez
and they start talking and david talks
about how he made justin cry and then
selena says
well then that makes two of us
so i want to know from you guys like
what do you think about this video what
do you think about selena publicly
dissing biebs i am not really sure how
to feel about it because i don't really
know if i care enough to really know how
i feel about it let's move on okay so i
need headphones where's my headphones at
because this app requires headphones i
want to show you guys this app it's
called the d articulator so basically
what it does is it kind of repeats what
you're saying into your own head
oh
i have extremely fragile hair so i found
this it i think it was like some sally
beauty supply salon store it has these
really fine little
bristles it's called the tangle teaser i
don't even know who makes it it's like
magic
you know
that's all i have to say about that if
you have fine hair it's like oh my god i
just feel like a pretty princess right
now
where's my crown i don't want a crown
right now i'm too tired alright guys
thanks for watching i love you make sure
you like this video by clicking the
little thumbs up button don't forget to
subscribe so you'll see the next video
that i post here we're here in miami so
i promise you we will have some fun
videos coming up this weekend
we just sit at the pool and do nothing
but
it's
pretty likely i love you guys i'll see
you later bye